one of the reasons i don't love
kamala pete
joe still a little bit um
klobuchar is because they are
team dem democrats in a sense and
they're institutionalized and trump eats
politicians for breakfast actually
breakfast lunch and dinner and it's too
easy of a lane for him
because he just could say everything's
bad because of these people he just gets
the point finger the whole time and he's
been that forever it's authentic people
identify with it hill hammer at home
when here's my question for you so in
2016 before you ran
um
in my mind's eye i was like how do you
beat trump and my two ideas were either
the whole party lines up behind like the
plain vanilla candidate which we ended
up doing it was joe but some were like
all right this guy's like passable it
doesn't matter just get trump out
or
a i thought it had to be a young
anonymous um
i thought it had to be a male to kind of
combat his masculine energy but like an
unknown coming out of nowhere and maybe
combating with a certain type of of new
politics and and pete was that and you
were that you both kind of checked that
box um
but
i'm trying to look at 2024 and i'm
curious your thoughts on if you let's
blank slate and i know it's not really
fair but theoretically how do you defeat
him
what is this round three i guess this is
round three if trump running for
president right
yeah so i i think that if the democrats
were to get behind someone like a mark
cuban uh that would be the best approach
to defeat
trump because you have someone who's a
mavericky no pun intended mavericky
billionaire businessman
who is a capital i independent
he's not a creature of the establishment
he's not like these i think if you run
anyone who smacks of washington dc
or capital d democrat you lose
uh like you need to go outside of your
own
um
backyard or in crowd um and get someone
who actually can make a similar case to
trump and say okay
things suck it's a mess
we need real change and i represent real
change one of my beliefs is that
uh americans have just been casting
about for change over and over again
like obama was changed
bernie was changed trump was change
joe strangely enough was changed from
trump because people were like okay like
i'm a little bit tired of
[Laughter]
this stick during the pandemic
um and then now people in my opinion are
getting tired of joe and then if if you
run
uh
amy or pete or kamala they're gonna be
the establishment and they're they're
gonna have a tough they're probably
gonna lose to trump um so you need to go
outside of the establishment and get
someone um i think cuban would make
sense i think if you were to go really
far out like you and get
even like a well-loved celebrity figure
um
like
uh an oprah or the rock or le you know
like one of these types
um you know i i think it would steal a
lot of the thunder from trump you know
i mean there are a lot of people that
just again they want to change they want
someone independent of the machine they
want someone who can hold their
attention
in a positive way
uh you know and not and not just say
political pablum that's [ __ ]
[Laughter]
um so so that this is
oh the the thing i want to emphasize is
like look
we can see that disaster is coming down
the pike uh in 24.
um and so you should be thinking
about trying to avert disaster and not
just kind of trundle along do the thing
that comes naturally and oh by the way
you're going to lose and then you know
extra x months later we're looking up
being like okay what that will happen
so number one is trying to actually win
fair and square along with the votes
and then number two would be to try and
make sure that the vote count matters
because
they're going to be trying to undermine
and subvert election findings
the whole time
there are tens of millions of americans
that now are on board with that general
narrative and just refuse to believe
that trump loses unless it's stolen from
him
um uh and i i said something to someone
that i believe and it's gonna be tough
if trump runs i have a hard time
imagining a scenario where we don't have
some type of
widespread political violence
and unrest in in 24
because if trump
wins straight up which again i see as
right now
probably the most likely scenario um
with some of the opponents that we we've
described right then there are protests
around the country because trump won
again and you know you'd have
um
uh
people in blue states and urban areas
and other other places um protesting
you'd probably have people show up in dc
protesting
um
certainly you know after trump resumed
living in the white house um but i think
there'd be protests immediately um and
if trump loses and claims victory then
you'd have uh political violence uh
from the other direction where you'd
have tons of
uh maga folks out in the street saying
the election was stolen again
um i think that those people will be
spoiling for a fight particularly after
trump spends months ginning them up
um
if he's running
so you are looking at a really really
bleak tempestuous tough
uh
season um and so one of the questions is
how can you try and strengthen
people's sense of resolve around
uh the vote and voting and other things
um now this is some of the work that i'm
doing with the forward party
which is i think in 22
there is a chance that you can shift
certain environments from party
primaries to
open primaries
that could change in the incentives for
critical mass of republican legislators
who could then look up and maybe uh pass
legislation saying you can't
fire secretaries of state or you know
you can't like for no reason or you
can't just have state legislators
uh decide who the electoral votes go to
uh you know that's not the point of
of the state legislators certifying is
not just a you know counteract the will
of the people
um so we have a
an opportunity in 2022 that everyone
should be staring at
um and
a lot of the action is around
um modern republicans who don't like
trump but feel like if they say a bad
word about him then their career is
going to be over or worse yet that their
families are going to be threatened did
you read the article in the atlantic
about peter meyer and his
experience
so i thought this was very very
compelling there were 10 members of
congress who voted to impeach donald
trump right um and originally it was
looking like 20 and then it just went
down and down and down because all of
them were being threatened
um and so this is an article by our
friend tim alberta in the atlantic about
peter meyer who by the way is only 33
years old had just taken his seat just
shows up and then is getting asked to
vote whether to impeach trump and then
he's getting text messages from everyone
being like don't do it don't do it don't
do it and then he kind of stared long
and hard in the mirror and was like i
think i have to do it
and uh and then he
ended up having his um
you know like his safety threatened and
like all this stuff and and all these
members of congress and so there's
there's this thing where apparently a
bunch of people were in the same
situation but they a lot of them just
decided out of fear for their own
physical safety to just be like i'm not
going to vote
impeach trump
um and and that to me
it's a very very worthwhile read uh this
tim alberta piece about peter meyer and
i i met peter meyer um i've actually
known him socially for a while because i
did work in detroit and
he's been uh you know working hard on
economic development um for a long time
so i like peter
um i find him to be very reasonable uh
and principled so he did the right thing
in in this direction and
paid a massive price
but interestingly peter seems like he's
going to
um actually get reelected um
for a variety of reasons but of the
members of congress who voted to impeach
trump of those 10 two have already said
they're not running again anthony
gonzalez in ohio and then adam kinzinger
in illinois
um
which is a huge loss so you have a very
very small number of republicans who
decided to
stand up to trump and it hasn't gone
well for them i mean that's the main
thing in this article is that the people
who decided to stand up for principle
were not shielded or rewarded
[Music]
you